hey everybody its Jeff clima new media
rock stars I'm sitting here with the
beautiful youtube sensation olgakay
thank you yeah we are we're in the
Barbie room as I recall this this room
got 106 thousand or so so views just to
watch you painted is that correct yep so
pretty much people will watch beautiful
girls do anything huh yeah as long as
they wear tutus as I am right now yeah
and you look fantastic the most colorful
person I think I've ever met so it's
good so all right well in in the course
of doing my interview prep I happen to
watch a few of your videos and I
happened to catch one late last night
and which I believe you said I have an
interview coming up tomorrow photo shoot
and I don't want to do it you did and I
was like oh that's good i'm gonna
definitely ask her about that it was
obviously my olgakay to channel why
would i say i don't want to do it you
were like I'd rather be playing
assassin's creed or mine from so are you
pretty big gamers I guess what I'm
asking I love video games no I'm
actually really excited about this photo
shoot because we came up with this
concept of being Japanese street style
person and I haven't dressed up like
this in a while so I'm actually really
excited um although I make 23 videos a
week so I'm a little behind on my
schedule because I've been doing a lot
of different things that you know not
supposed to happen during the week
usually all right now where are you from
because you have such a beautiful little
accent oh thank you I was born by the
Black Sea in the Ukraine but if I go
home now
my home is in Siberia which is in Russia
and that's where my parents are living
right now okay and you have brothers and
sisters I do have an older brother he's
not here I'm here by myself and he's a
DJ so he's still in Russia and he has a
wife and her name is Olga and my and her
name is Olga so there's like old as in
my family everywhere so if we get for a
family get-together nobody knows who
they're talking to but ok so how did you
get into YouTube then by force ok wow
they took me and they said you gonna be
on YouTube no my friend I used to be in
the circus and I used to juggle and you
knew that right I did not know that now
ok so used to be in the circus and I had
a lot of friends that are jugglers and
my friend of mine who was a juggler he
put up a video on youtube and he said
hey Olga can you create an account on
YouTube and like and favorite my video
and back then we had star system so he
said can you give me five stars and I
said you two has a website well yeah
like no it's YouTube it's this new thing
video hosting site so i signed up and i
used my bank password which was Olga Kay
and I feel like whenever I'm just going
to create this account and like his
video give him five stars so I did that
and I started reading the comments and
like who are these people why are they
watching this video I don't understand
maybe I should put up a video and I had
no I didn't have a camera I didn't know
how to edit I had two cats that somebody
filmed the video off and edited I'm like
oh I'll just put that up so I put that
up and people started watching a little
bit and then I realized that I have to
learn how to edit and get a camera and I
couldn't afford to get a camera back
then so I had a laptop and it was a mac
laptop with an eyesight and I literally
ran around town with the computer
filming myself making videos
I tell me about what's the YouTube
influence like saying the Black Sea is
there is your strong YouTube following
out there you know when I left youtube
didn't even exist so I've been here for
12 years and when I discovered youtube
it was like so exciting it was a new
thing and nobody knew anything about it
even in America so I went to Russia last
year and I started looking right I just
changed my channel to Russia region
because I wanted to see if I'm going to
be number one in Russia and I was number
three so there is actually number one
and number two channel and now it's
pretty big and people make careers out
of it but literally in the last maybe
year and a half now Aidan one of your
videos use the term who gave birth to
you is that something your mom used to
say to you and louder I had a meeting
with my writers the other day and so I
would say little things like oh if this
video doesn't do well I'm gonna hang
myself and then tickle my feet and
they're like wait is that something you
say in Russian like actually no I just
make it up I just made it up I just felt
like when people are acting a certain
way and they're not good people I just
want to say who gave birth to you like
what kind of mother do have that raised
you a certain way so I just made it up
we didn't say that in Russia okay now
did you also make up your theory about
dealing with [ __ ] is that uh how is
it to imagine that they have an [ __ ]
right there with their face should be
did see my imagination is a little
whacking out there I like it it's a good
imagination now thanks how do you how do
you think you became so successful
though a lot of hard work okay because I
been one of those youtubers that never
got super lucky and got this viral hit
hit where everyone been watching and
talking about like chocolate rain or
like I've never had any of those videos
so for me it was literally doing it day
after day you spent 12 hours a day not
that I don't now but 12 hours a day with
no money just believing in this thing
that I wasn't sure if it's gonna go
anywhere hmm but for some reason I love
doing it so I kept doing it forever and
going to YouTube gatherings meeting
people telling them hey I can juggle
balls and I'm amazed me watch my videos
I used to have this business cards and
it would be me in my circus costume and
I would have juggling balls there and
says Russian juggler and I would pass
him out everywhere like I was the first
youtuber who constantly passing out
cards with my youtube on it and so
people started watching me a little bit
but it still took me a good two or three
years to gain the momentum on youtube so
as a so I'm gonna need you for six years
but as of maybe three months ago I
finally came up with the schedule so I
wake up in the morning I upload all of
my videos that are due that day on
monday i think i'm uploading 1 2 3 4
videos and that once i'm finished
uploading i'm doing my makeup and i do a
shoot for my beauty channel and my
gaming channel and hopefully i will be
done by 5pm so then i can either edit a
little bit or just relax and spend time
with my friends then on tuesday i'm
shooting more videos for my beauty
channel wednesday i'm editing and
uploading 5 videos because that's
actually the day when i upload on my
main channel then thursday i should have
sketch for my main channel and then
friday i'm shooting more gaming videos
and then the weekend if I'm lucky I get
to relax if not I'll just edit or give
my editor notes and I finally got an
editor and cameraman in the last I don't
know seven months but I've been doing
this whole thing by myself and it's been
a lot of work you know recently I've
been noticing that
what is a you know a lot of people tell
me hey you're not in myself la la and I
feel like I follow all the formulas that
are out there to be successful on
YouTube and still I see the decline and
I'm for myself I think that every time I
make a video I have to go in little step
for further it may be funnier or more
interesting or more captivating so I'm
constantly changing my formats to see
what works and sometimes an amazing
video drops on my channel and it doesn't
go anywhere and it makes me super sad I
cry for this guy I don't but you know it
makes me wonder like what is it because
then I see somebody make a video and it
didn't get much work into it it's kind
of that funny but it just blows up so
you just never know what works and what
doesn't so for me I just try to stay
true to who I am I tried to be as funny
as possible and connect to my audience
you have any you have any plans for say
post youtube or are you just kind of
taking it one day at a time and see you
know no I'm constantly thinking ahead
all the time and realizing that you can
have all the opportunities if millions
of people watching on YouTube so when I
see lots of people that have millions of
views and you would think that everyone
just wants to snatch them up and do
something with them and they don't take
that opportunity it really makes me
watch people with this notes all right
you know what and you were like or you
stay there because and and I feel that's
the only thing that is holding me back
and I have huge ambitions I want to do a
lot of great things I wanted to design
clothes for people like for young kids
bring out girls because my style is
really funky and I really don't care and
I don't follow a certain style I just
put something together that is cool and
like kiss everyone's gonna want to wear
this so I want to design clothes and
have my own perfume and be in movies and
there's like so many things that I want
to do and I feel like if I had those
opportunities it would be so much easier
not complaining I've done a lot of cool
things
but yet there's definitely a lot of
things that I won't do outside of
YouTube and I'm not saying that YouTube
is just a stepping stone that's actually
my business and I would never stop doing
it but i would love to branch out as i
say i love to branch out and just put
myself in different and like you said
the age thing um because it worries me
well people watch me before you probably
not unless i have a cooking show and
nobody's gonna watch that so i always
think of ways of you know doing things
outside and just creating a life outside
if YouTube disappears tomorrow I still
have to be some kind of a brand that
people want to follow
now here are some of the other people
that you follow oh gosh I follow
everyone on YouTube like I said I've
been on youtube since 2006 so I've
literally been watching everyone my
first person that I watched on YouTube
was lonely girl 15 and so cool is this
girl so fascinating what she's an
actress which I had no problem I thought
it was awesome and lisanova was one of
the first people that I watched and now
I just watch everybody if we talk about
females I love jenna Marbles and Daily
Grace and I think they're like my
inspiration now yes awesome females that
are super funny and as far as guys I
mean there's so many so many great guys
who do i watch honestly I make so many
videos now I rarely watch videos unless
it's you know my friends are like hey we
made this awesome video let's check it
out um but yes I watched when I have
time I watch a lot of my friends
everybody and no everyone lives in LA so
it's like a big family now what is the
wild and crazy olgakay have coming up
next well I'll never stop making that it
is I have a musical music video coming
out when is this interview gonna go well
that's a good question is a couple weeks
so okay so I have the two weeks so i'll
say well I have a really cool music
video coming out and it's called boning
my mom okay my boyfriend is boning my
mom can I have a problem and I'm just
getting into a start making like music
parodies so I'm really excited but I
also and you host I don't even know if
I'm allowed to talk about this but I
recently was sign up to do hosting for
power up season 2 which is a new Disney
show on YouTube and it's all about video
games it's really cool so Olga thank you
very much for taking the time to sit
down with new media rock stars and let
us get to know you thank you guys for
coming thank you cameras moosh I love
you moosh I love you more and
uh where's my dog yeah where is that dog
roxy is a cutie she is hi guys yes take
it easy thank you very much thanks for
watching this interview you guys if you
want to check out the full interview
just go to a new media rockstars calm
and check it out there's awesome
pictures lots of words that have said
here go read them if you like reading
he'll see soon bye moosh
could have all died